recently the hill published a report
telling us what we already know which is
that Americans love going to therapy
according to the outlet quote the number
of Americans seeking mental health
treatment is almost twice as high as it
was two decades ago reflecting a
historic recent decline in mental health
but also an increase in Virtual care and
positive trends of destigmatization in
2004 just 13 percent of adults said that
they had visited a therapist
psychiatrist or other mental health
professional within the past year
according to Gallup polling in 2022 that
number was up to 23 percent the article
also puts a lot of the blame on covid
but these are all trends that far
predate covet and face time in fact I
found an article from the American
Psychological Association noting the
significant increase in Americans
seeking Mental Health Services and that
article was published in 2004 so in 2004
they were already noticing this big
increase in people going to therapy and
now we know compared to 2004 it's
doubled since then